من بلده جاءت في المرتبه الحاديه والعشرين
ضمن قائمه افضل القرى السياحيه حول العالم
خلال عام 2022 وفقا لمنظمه السياحه
العالميه طبعا نتحدث عن البلده القديمه في
العلا التحفه التي تقع في الضيق جزء من
الوادي الاثري البلده تتميز بمبانيها
القديمه التي تشبه المتاهه شيدت بالطوب
اللبن في القرن العاشر ولا تزال قائمه حتى
يوم من هذا تظن نحو 900 منزل واربعمائه
وخمس ساعات في المدينه اقدم مبانيها قلعه
موسى بن نصير المطله على مناظر المدينه
الخلابه يعود تاريخها الى القرن السادس
قبل الميلاد كانت ماهوله في الماضي غير
البعيد وفي القرن الثاني عشر فتحت ابوابها
للمسافرين وكاله نقطه التقاء الرحاله
والحجاج من دمشق الى مكه المكرمه ومن هناك
تتسلوا علينا وتنورنا اليوم زميله لدينا
نبدا اولا بالتقرير الذي اعدته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن الان في البلده القديمه في العلا
عمرها سبعه قرون تعد نموذج للترابط
الاجتماعي الذي تمتاز به العلا منذ القدم
تكونت من اكثر من 900 مبنى تم تشهيدها من
الطوب الطيني وهي محاطه ايضا بعدد من
القلاع لاغراض الحمايه والرقابه لاهالي
العلا وقوافل الحجيج وكانت في السابق
عباره عن اربع عشره بواب عند مداخل العلا
وهي تعمل وفق اجراءات محدده بالدخول
والخروج لتامين مسار قوافل الحشيش
[موسيقى]
منظمه السياحه العالميه تختار البلده
القديمه في العلا كواحده من افضل القرى
السياحيه في عام 20 22 بما يتوافق مع
معايير الاختيار المعتمده لاختيار القرى
السياحيه كمحرك للتنميه تدعم خلق فرص
جديده للوظائف وتلتزم ايضا بالابتكار
والاستدامه بجميع عناصرها الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه والبيئه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لما تطوير البلده القديمه في العلا لتكون
منطقه جذب سياحي بالعديد من المطاعم
المقاهي والمتاجر الصغيره لابناء العلا في
منتجاتهم المحل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الهيئه الملكيه
لاعاده ورش البلده القديمه ياتي اهتمام
الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا في البلده
القديمه لما تحمله وتسخر به من ارث تاريخ
وثقافه وفن معماري فريد بعد ان اذن ديثار
اجزاء منها منذ بدايات القرن التاسع عشر
الميلادي حيث كانت منطقه مهجوره في معظم
اطرافها الى ان الجهود الشامله لتنميه
المستدامه اعادتها لتكون وجهه ثقافيه
وسياحيه لاهالي وزوار العلا لصباح العربيه
نادي الخماش العلاقه
[موسيقى]
من العلا تنضم الينا من جديد زميل نادين
اهلا بك من جديد نورتنا تكوني معنا اهلا
بك يا نادين مره ثانيه حدثينا اليوم عن
البلده القديمه
من اجمل القرى السياحيه في 2022 ولماذا
تسمى البلده التاريخيه والبلده القديمه يا
نادين وبوابه التاريخ
يسعد صباحك يا سهام مجددا وسنبدا ببيت شعر
ولقد اجر الليله في وادي القرى نشوان بين
مزارع ونخيلي ونحن الان متواجدون بين
مزارع ونخيل في البلده القديمه في العلب
نتذكر سهام انه تقريبا قبل اسبوعين من
الان كنا انا وانت في فقره في صباح
العربيه وتحدثنا عن تصنيف لاجمل القرى
السياحيه العالميه في عام 2022 وكانت
البلده القديمه في العلا واحده من افضل
القلاله العالميه التي صنفت من اجلها
الوجهات السياحيه في عام 20 22
امسجولنا في البلده القديمه ونحن الان
متواجدين في البلده القديمه هل لكم ان
تتخيلوا بان هذه المنطقه كانت مهجوره قبل
ان يتم ترميمها وان تتكثف الجهود لكي يعود
هذه الحركه وتعود هذه الحركه الى هذه
البلده نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 900 هذه
المباني دخلناها امس عندما اردنا الذهاب
الى ساعه طنطوره هذه الساعه الطينيه
الساعه الشمسيه فعلا كان متاهه يعني تدخل
من بيت متلاصق مع بيت اخر عندما تريدين ان
تخرجي الى البيت الذي يليها او البيت الذي
بعده قد تتوهي يعني فعلا هي متاهه كما
تسمى هذه البيوت ما زال بعضها قيد الترميم
وايضا نقيد الانشاء لانها كانت بيوت
مهجوره يعني نتحدث عن سنين عده هذه البلده
عمرها سبعه قرون يعني فبالتالي بيوت قديمه
اليوم نلاحظ دمش الحاضر بالتاريخ بالماضي
يعني هذا هو شارع البلده القديمه في مقاهي
في متاجر وهذه المتاجر هي متاجر صغيره
لاهالي العلا وايضا منتجات محليه الصنع
فبالتالي هذه المفارقه وهذا التناقض هو
الذي جعل هذا الشارع وهذه البلده القديمه
فيها ميزه يعني اليوم محلات مطاعم وكوفي
شوبس هي مرتبطه بالحاضر
وبالتالي البلده القديمه لم تفقد بريقها
لم تفقد وهجها المتعلق بالتراث والفن
والعماره والحضاره القديمه سمعتني نادين
هلا سمعتني طيب بس السؤال الاخير نادين
قبل ما نرجع لك مره ثانيه انا كسائح بدي
ازور بلده القديمه السوق كل شيء متوفر
[موسيقى]
للسياح كل شيء متوفر وعلى فكره صار فيه
كمان حتى زي عربات تسير داخل شارع البلده
القديمه بتسهل على الناس الماشي كمان في
لوحات
ترشيديه وتعلم كل المعلومات التي تتعلق في
هذه المنطقه وفي هذا الجبل مثلا وفي هذا
الحجر سيرين انت في الشوارع ايضا في لوحات
في اللغتين الانجليزيه والعربيه لانه
لاحظنا كمان سها مكثره للسياح وايضا كنا
في قلعه العلا يوم امس الموجوده القديمه
وسعدنا 190 درجه يوم امس حتى نصل اليها
سهام يعني هالمره انا اقول لك يا زين
عيشتك يا نادين مش لايف ههه شكرا جزيلا
نادين